although there were way too many notable
characters on friends to mention
all of them we ranked the endings of
some of the most significant players
taking into account where they started
where they wound up and what happened to
them along the way
poor emily waltham wound up being the
person most damaged by ross and rachel's
off-again on-again relationship
at emily's wedding to ross seeing rachel
distracts the groom and he
accidentally says rachel's name during
his vows i ross
take the emily take thee rachel
emily goes through at the wedding but
then immediately runs away
mortified by the actions of her new
husband later
ross convinces her to try to make the
marriage work but she's so
jealous of rachel that she forbids him
to see her or even keep
anything she ever touched ultimately
emily's conditions proved too much for
ross
and their brief marriage ends however
that's not the last we hear from emily
i'm getting married tomorrow well maybe
i am
i keep thinking about you and i'm
wondering if
if we made a mistake ross doesn't take
her up on the offer to get back together
but emily's ending doesn't speak to a
character who's moved on in a healthy
way
david was introduced in the first season
of friends and quickly hit it off with
phoebe
only to reveal that he would soon be
leaving the country to pursue scientific
study
in minsk the two briefly reconnect years
later
when david comes to town for one night
and phoebe drops
everything to see him saying he could be
the love of her life
but he returns to minsk yet again and
phoebe
finally moves on and falls in love with
mike hannigan
david makes his last appearance in
season 9 returning to the united states
for good
after realizing that the scientific
breakthrough he was attempting to
achieve in minsk was
in fact impossible he prepares to
propose to phoebe
but mike proposes first david is left
alone without the woman he loves
or the scientific advancement he'd
worked for it's a pretty sad ending for
a character who never seems to have
things turn out the way he wants despite
their significant age gap
richard burke and monica quickly fall in
love in season two
but soon realize they want totally
different things in life
monica wants to have children of her own
but richard's kids are adults
and he doesn't want any more after some
painful deliberation
the two reluctantly break up several
years later
richard decides that he's willing to
have children if that's what it takes to
be with monica but by then
monica has fallen in love with chandler
who also wants to get married and have
children
accepting that monica already has
everything she wants
richard stops trying to pursue her as
far as we know he never remarries
but eventually winds up selling his
apartment to buy a much larger apartment
with a view of central park
so even if he remains alone he'll be
alone in style
the story of phoebe's teenage
half-brother frank buffet
jr takes a surprising turn when he tells
phoebe that he's fallen in love with his
home economics teacher
alice alice is several decades frank's
senior
but despite their scandalous age gap the
two get married
shortly after tying the knot frank and
alice hurry to have children
using phoebe as a surrogate much to
everyone's surprise phoebe becomes
pregnant with triplets
and frank and alice are thrilled however
in the final season of the show frank
comes to phoebe with an
unusual request i just was thinking that
you know maybe you could take one but
when pressed to pick one
frank realizes he can't bring himself to
part with any of his children
no matter how exhausted he is while
we're glad that frank comes to accept
his role as the father of triplets it's
a little concerning that he's so
overwhelmed
that he comes to the brink of giving
away one of his children
we hope he and alice eventually find a
better balance
gunther is a permanent fixture on
friends although he never gets much of a
story
of his own the one exception is his
long-standing crush
on rachel for most of the series gunther
has strong feelings for her and
experiences significant jealousy towards
the men she dates
occasionally this ventures into creepy
territory
but in the series finale gunther finally
tells rachel
about his feelings i i know you're
you're leaving tonight
but i just have to tell you
i love you even though she doesn't
reciprocate he seems
at peace that makes us hopeful that he's
realized that pining for a woman who
doesn't love him
isn't good for him and that he'll be
content to move on with his life
janice begins as chandler's girlfriend
but she continues popping up
long after their relationship ends in
season 8
janice shows up unexpectedly in the
hospital where rachel is giving birth
revealing that she's also having a baby
with her new
mostly deaf husband sid sid's limited
hearing makes him the perfect match for
janus
whose nasal voice and distinctive laugh
prove off-putting for most other
characters on the show
squeeze your legs together and cover the
baby's ears janice also appears in the
fertility clinic where monica and
chandler are trying to conceive
saying that she insider trying to have
another baby
janice's last appearance is as a
homebuyer who considers purchasing the
home next door to chandler and
monica she decides against it when
chandler pretends to still have feelings
for her
all in all janice seems to have done
pretty well for herself
finding a husband she loves and raising
a family while
always remaining true to herself one of
the most stable relationships throughout
friends is between ross's ex-wife carol
and her partner susan shortly after ross
and carol's son ben
is born following their divorce susan
and carol get married
they have a healthy marriage in which
they keep up a friendly relationship
with ross
the series never gives carol and susan a
definitive
ending but it checks in on them from
time to time mostly in the context of
their shared custody of ben with ross
mostly carol and susan appear to have a
loving and supportive relationship
which only intersects with ross when
they have to share parenting duties
otherwise the couple doesn't seem
wrapped up with carol's x at all
which is probably how it should be one
of the core group of friends
ross's ending well perfect in his own
eyes
comes in at the bottom of the stack
professionally he gets a tenured
position
at new york university he also continues
to share custody of his son with carol
although ben lives with his mom most of
the time on the romantic front
although ross dates many women
throughout the series he consistently
carries feelings for rachel
they have a daughter together emma in
season 8
but don't remain romantically involved
however in the series finale
as rachel prepares to take a job in
paris that would mark a huge step
forward in her career
ross realizes that he's still in love
with her he
asks her to remain in new york with him
and rachel agrees
while ross is overjoyed with her choice
it's hard to overlook that ross's happy
ending comes at the cost of rachel's
career
we can't help but wonder if it ever
crossed ross's mind
to offer to go to paris with rachel
instead of
begging her to give up her job to stay
with him
why do we always have to do everything
according to your
timetable lovable idiot joey tribiani is
the only friend still single by the
show's finale
and of the six main characters he
probably undergoes the least amount of
growth
joey spends years waiting for his big
acting break
which never really comes his biggest
success
is as dr drake ramore on days of our
lives but his character is killed off
only to be brought back to life several
seasons later joey
is nominated for an award for his
performance but never rises beyond that
role
romantically joey tends to avoid serious
relationships but is instrumental in
some of his friends relationships
and officiates two of their weddings he
ends the series on his own for the first
time
without either a roommate or best
friends across the hall
overall joey's ending is pretty
anticlimactic
with him serving more to support his
friend's conclusions than getting a
definitive ending of his own
rachel green begins friends as a spoiled
runaway bride with no marketable skills
and struggles as a waitress before
transitioning into a successful career
in fashion
once she's got her foot in the door
rachel gradually climbs the professional
ladder and
ultimately gets offered a job with louis
vuitton which requires her to move to
paris
she makes arrangements to move along
with her daughter and is on the plane to
leave when ross proclaims his love for
her in the finale
after getting off the plane to stay with
ross rachel ends the series romantically
happy
however after flaking out on the paris
job one has to wonder whether she's shot
herself in the foot
professionally the finale doesn't
grapple with this question
but considering how much of rachel's arc
focuses on the hard work she puts into
her career it's a little disappointing
to see her give that all up
in the finale the free spirit of the
group
phoebe buffet spends the entire series
as a masseuse who enjoys performing
original songs at central perk
however while phoebe doesn't go through
any major professional changes
she does experience some big life events
in season 4
she agrees to act as a surrogate for her
brother and his wife
and she gives birth to triplets then
after having mostly casual relationships
phoebe meets mike hannigan in season 9
and the two
soon fall in love an easy going piano
player with a similarly quirky sense of
humor to phoebe's
mike proves the perfect compliment to
phoebe's eccentric nature
the couple gets married by joey in
season 10 in an impromptu
outdoor ceremony and in the series
finale mike tells phoebe that he'd like
to have
a baby you want to make one of those one
how about a whole bunch
really yeah oh we can teach them to sing
and we can be like the von trapp family
her ending is fitting for a character
who never compromises who she is
but isn't afraid to move on to the next
big thing
despite none of his friends having a
clear idea of what he does for a living
chandler is one of the most
professionally stable friends throughout
the series
building a successful career in data and
statistical analysis
however chandler doesn't like his job
and after accidentally accepting a
promotion that requires him to commute
to tulsa four days a week
he leaves his field and starts over as a
junior copywriter at an
advertising agency while this is
technically a step back for him
professionally
it's also the first step towards a
career he actually enjoys
romantically chandler goes through a
number of unsuccessful relationships
before falling for monica
starting his best friends proves to be
exactly what they both need and the two
perfectly balance out each other's
neuroses monica and chandler get married
in a wedding officiated by joey and
chandler becomes a father in the series
finale
when he and monica adopt twins and move
to the suburbs to raise them it's a huge
amount of growth for a character
who started out immature and afraid of
commitment and it's a tremendously
satisfying way to wrap up his story
monica begins as a struggling chef who
longs to fall in love
settle down and start a family over the
following 10 seasons she makes
significant strides in every area of her
life
although each is hard won professionally
after a string of less than successful
career moves
monica ultimately accepts her dream job
at javu
an upscale manhattan eatery on the
relationship front
monica first finds love with richard but
makes the hard decision to break it off
when she realizes
he has no desire for more children
eventually she falls for chandler
and the two get married however after a
year spent trying to get
pregnant they learn they can't conceive
and decide to adopt instead
the couple is chosen by a young pregnant
woman named erica who doesn't realize
she's carrying twins
until she's already delivered the first
baby twins
twins taylor you're panicking uh-huh
join me won't you after adjusting to the
shock of twins
monica and chandler and the series
preparing to move to the suburbs to
raise their children
it's the perfect ending for monica's
control freak character
with nothing happening exactly the way
she planned but with her still getting
everything she ever wanted check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one